Comme vous le voyez à mes cernes , moi je suis
un mec qui dort plutôt bien. PHÔ ! (faux)
Je sais pas vous, mais moi depuis tout petit
je suis un très grand insomniaque
Pour vous donner un ordre d'idée, je fais en moyenne une insomnie ...
Toutes les nuits.
Quand j'arrive pas à dormir, je fais toujours les mêmes trucs inutiles.
Déjà j'essaie toutes les positions possibles du corps humain :
"Ah... là c'est bien, là !"
Je regarde des trucs à la con sur le net.
"Putain.... Putain ! PUTAIIIIIN !"
Je bois de l'eau, je fais pipi, je bois de l'eau, je fais pipi.
Je bois de l'eau en faisant pipi.
J'essaie de me faire croire que je lis un livre alors qu'en fait je suis pas du tout concentré.
*Gniaaa !*  Je combats pendant une heure un moustique ...
Qui n'existe pas. "C'était une tache..."
Je crois avoir l'idée du siècle
alors je l'écris, je la relis...C'est de la pure merde...
Je la jette. Alors je retourne sur le net."PUTAAAAAIIIIN !" *Femme qui gémit*
les gens qui ont un bon sommeil parfois ils osent se plaindre
avec ce genre de remarque
"Moi je dors trop, du coup je suis fatigué de trop dormir"
J'ai envie dire, il y a quand même pire comme problème
Disons que sur l'échelle des problèmes les plus graves dans le monde
On est pas sur un top 3, hein ?
Ouiiiii
Les gens qui ont pas de problème de sommeil
Ils aiment bien te donner des p'tits conseils
Pfffff...moi je sais pas, pour t'endormir...
Essaie de penser à rien
Allez je pense à rien
C'est parti...
Je pense à rien...
Attends mais là je pense au fait de penser à rien...
Putain...
Alors, pour éviter les insomnies
Il parait qu'il faut pas regarder des écrans
Au moins une heure avant d'aller dormir
Et franchement chaque soir, j'essaie de le faire
Allez, une heure avant de dormir
J'arrête la télé
*rires*
Bon allez, J'arrête l'ordi
Allez, J'arrête le téléphone
Quand je fais une insomnie
Je suis énervé de pas dormir
Alors je m'énerve, mais j'ai personne contre qui m'énerver
C'est assez ridicule
Putain ça me saoul de pas dormir
Maintenant tu dors ok?
Tu vas dormir...
Ok ?
Chaque année, des milliers d'oreillers sont frappés à cause d'insomnie
Soutenez les, envoyez vos plumes
Pour les rembourrer
Je suis victime de maltraitance
En plus y'a bien un truc qui est sûr
C'est que c'est pas en t'énervant, que tu vas réussir à t'endormir
PUTAIIIIIIIIN !!!
On a tous eu çe prof chiant au collège
Qui nous endormait en 3 secondes
À chacun de ses cours
Mais des fois je me dis...
Ce prof là, mine de rien
Il pourait être une bonne solution
Contre l'insomnie
Âllo, monsieur Bouchard ?
Oui ?
Ouais, Norman Thavaud...
5e B
En 99
Oui?
Vous pouvez me refaire çe petit cours sur la trigonométrie, là?
Bien sûr
(Grand 1, petit a)
La trigonométrie est une branche...
ZZzzzzz...
Parfois j'arrive pas à dormir
Parce que j'ai une chanson dans la tête
Mais attention, c'est pas un petit morceau cool, qui fait plaisir.
Non, c'est toujours deux secondes d'une chanson pourrie
♪♪♪ Zéro Tracas Zéro Blabla ♪♪♪
Allez...
Bon en général je me lève
Pour me changer une peu les idées
Bah je sais pas je regarde la télé
"Et tout de suite une page de pub"
♪♪♪ Zéro Tracas Zéro Blabla ♪♪♪
Oh non...
J'ai même regardé sur youtube
Des vidéos d'hypnose
Pour s'endormir
Fait par des pros et tout...
Alors je trouve que le concept est génial
Mais sur moi perso...
Ça a pas trop marché
"Je vais simplement vous inviter à écouter ma voix"
"Celui qui va... vous faire voyager vers le sommeil et solidement ancré sur le sol"
"La terre..."
"Est posée dans le système solaire"
Je suis angoissé là
"Alors même..."
"Que déja..."
"Alors même que déja..."
Oui bonsoir, j'aimerais une pizza quatre fromages
"Ouvrez les yeux tranquillement"
"Tire toi le chat"
Alors c'est un peu cruel
Mais moi quand j'arrive pas à dormir
J'aime bien réveiller les autres
Du coup je me sens moins seul
Ça me réconforte
Et je m'endors
C'est psychologique
Hé...
Quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a pourquoi tu me réveilles
ZZZZZZzzzzzzzz....
Je sais pas si vous c'est pareil
Mais moi avant de dormir...
J'ai un vieux toc
De systématiquement calculer le nombre d'heures que je vais avoir de sommeil
Si je mets mon réveil à huit heures
Ça me fait sept heures de sommeil
Moins trente minutes pour me préparer demain matin
Plus le facteur inconnu "x" qui correspond à une insomnie potentielle
D'une durée de deux à quatre heures
Résultat mon nombre d'heures de sommeil sera de...
83 heures de sommeil
Eh ben...
T'es toujours autant une merde en maths, toi
Tu mérites bien d'être Youteubeur
Souvent tu dors pas parce que t'es stressé par l'heure qui défile
Tu vois ta nuit se réduire peu à peu
Du coup en cas d'insomnie..
Il parait qu'il faut pas regarder l'heure
Ce qui est je trouve...
Une torture
Allez je mets la radio 10 minutes
Je me détends et après je dors
"Vous êtes sur Radio puissance dans l'émission nocturne et il est 3 heures du matin"
Oh non...
"On se retrouve après cette page de pub"
♪♪♪ Zéro Tracas Zéro Blabla ♪♪♪
Oh putain...
Putain !
Il existe mille et un conseils pour mieux dormir
Mais au final chacun a ses propres méthodes
Moi par exemple je sais que très souvent je dors pas parce que je réfléchis trop
Et parfois juste un proche, une personne qui t'aime
Peut trouver les mots pour te rassurer, T'apaiser...
Et la forcément tu trouves le sommeil
Norman, ta réunion elle est importante demain...
Mais tu joues pas ta vie on s'en fout
Ouais on s'en fout ouais
Peut-être que tu vas piquer du nez et alors?
Et alors ? On les emmerde !
Peut-être que tu seras viré, et alors?
Peut-être que t'es pas fait pour ce métier
Peut être que t'es fait pour devenir troubadour...
Ouais arrête, Stop
Préfère quand tu me rassures pas
C'est...c'est plus rassurant
(♪ Générique de Un Gars, Une Fille ♪)
Nikel, Merci, Bonne nuit!
Bah c'est pas si mal troubadour
(♪ Générique de Un Gars, Une Fille ♪)
(En l'imitant) Eh c'est pas si mal troubadour
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
Si vous avez apprécié...
Soyez cool
Mettez un énorme pouce en l'air
Durant mes nuits d'insomnie j'ai carrément écrit une petite fiction
Qui parle du sommeil
Destinée à ma chaine Youtube
J'espère que je pourrai bientôt la faire et vous la montrer
Et qu'elle vous plaira
Moi finalement j'ai pas top de remède, contre l'insomnie
Mais ce que je peux faire c'est vous laisser sur un comptage de moutons
Petite info bonus
Si vous avez aimé mon petit t-shirt que je porte dans la vidéo
Et ben vous pouvez aussi vous le procurer
Parce que c'est ma petite collection
De t-shirt que j'ai lancé
Je me suis fait un petit kiff
Y'a plein de t-shirts différents
En rapport à mes vidéos
Et plein de petits goodies
Le lien est dispo, dans la description
Voilà.
Bonne nuit...